hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over one of my favorite parts in
chess a very aggressive openings so sit
back relax and enjoy my list of the top
seven chess aggressive openings
number seven on the list we have the
Danish gambit one of the more common
openings that you'll see pani for pani
five and white just starts giving up
material as fast as possible starting
with pawn to d4 after it takes the pawn
just gonna come up here to c3 allowing
his opponent to continue to take that
material in his opponent doesn't have to
but the intent would be for this
opponent to take bishop here to see Ford
not even worrying if black takes more
material if black does continue to take
bishop here to b2 all of a sudden white
is down to pawns in material but as you
can see he has a very aggressive setup
both of his bishops are both eyeing down
on this King side black has none of his
pieces involved into the game
White has a fairly open lane for his
Queen to get involved both sides of the
board in the middle very easily can get
his Knights very easily involved Castle
queenside or King side depending on if
he needs some safety or if it wants to
be very aggressive so Danish gambit
definitely one of the openings that
you'll get a lot of opportunities to
play so it definitely makes my list of
the best chess aggressive openings
number six in our list is the cochran
gambit definitely one of my favorites
after pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight here to
f3 pretty common moves from both side if
black tries the petrov defense which is
not the most common but you do see it
every now and then whites usually going
to respond with Knight to e5 followed by
pawn to d6 kicking this Knight back the
night usually comes back here to f3 and
then we see the knight take here on e4
and things continue but this is kind of
boring and I like aggressive opening so
instead of whites moving his Knight back
and the Cochran game he's actually going
to play Knight to f7 now he's going to
be giving up his Knights early on now
black pretty much needs to take this
material he's gonna lose his queen or
his rook which seems extremely bad so he
needs to take this but this is going to
be completely fine this is what white
wants in this position he's given up a
knight and material and in exchange he
has two pawns and his opponent's king is
wide open and white can pretty much
attack it the rest of the game so
there's a separate video on that so I
want to go into a but definitely a fun
fun aggressive opening
the next regressive opening to make our
list is the Scotch gambit starts out
with pawn to e4 upon e5
I love Pawnee of four openings Knight to
f3 knight c6 and then pawn to d4 this is
the scotch game the scotch game is
typically pretty slow pretty boring
until someone came up with these Scotch
gambits which makes it all the more
interesting so after the pawn takes here
on d4 White's going to forego taking
this material here on d4 you know you
could see an exchange of the Knights and
the Knights here but instead White's
going to play Bishop here to c4 and he's
gonna have a very very strong attack
that he's going to start so again the
Scotch gambit if you're definitely
looking for a way to kind of spice up
the scotch game this is definitely your
opening
the next aggressive opening to make our
list you guessed it it is the Kings
gambits my favorite personal opening to
play pawn to e4 pawn e5 and then pawn to
f4 giving up material if you haven't
played this before it's definitely great
for an only beginners but those people
have been playing for a long time after
the pawn takes here on f4 usually Knight
to f3 this is kind of the way I play you
can play Bishop here to c4 if you want
to but so many fantastic lines that
actually want to go over one of my
favorites because it's also extremely
aggressive and so I'll keep it with the
King's gambit and that is the musio
gambit and so your opponent won't always
play into this but if they play pawn to
g5 the typical way for Kings gambit
would be to play pawn to h4 and then
when they push down you play your Knight
to g5 and then you look to get your
bishop involved but this pawn right here
is kind of allowing for an outpost on g5
the musio game it just doesn't really
care about all that it's always trying
to get more pieces involved into the
action so it plays Bishop here to see
for the pawns gonna push forward
attacking this knight white doesn't care
why it's just gonna castle on the King
side and pretty much give up that
material so after the pawn takes the
Queen takes right here and all of a
sudden if you look at this setup that
the King sides kind of weakened for
black he has no pieces really involved
into the action except this lowly pawn
here on f4 all of a sudden from White's
perspective he's castled he's got his
queen involved he's got his bishop
involved things are going to be very
very difficult for blacks to kind of
hold on to all the aggression that White
has so not only is the King's gambit
pretty fun and aggressive but the musio
gambit takes it to a whole nother level
the next aggressive opening we're going
to be looking at is the Halloween gambit
is extremely risky but it is so much fun
to play starts out with pawn to e4 if
people are curious why e4 is a pretty
common occurrence it's this opens up the
door for the LightSquared bishop to get
the Queen involved into the game usually
e4 is a much more aggressive opening so
that's why a lot of the openings have
efore in it but pawn to e5 and then we
have kind of the four Knights game so
Knight to c3 after Knight to c6 then we
have Knight to f3 and the Halloween's
gambit is Knight taking here on e5 which
seems a little crazy and it is which is
why it makes the video Knight ticking
here on e5 the pawns gonna push forward
to a d4 if the knight comes back here to
c6 we kind of just push forward again we
can kind of force it to come back here
so very aggressive just continuously
pushing forcing black to really just
move his Knights across the board he
could try another Knight move but all in
all Weiss is gonna be pushing forward
with his pawns trying to control the
center give his Bishop involved his
queen has some support right here
definitely a fun opening and although
Weitzman down a material many times if
black doesn't play perfectly white can
get that back so definitely a fun
opening but very risky as well
the next regressive opening we're going
to be looking at is our only opening
from blacks perspective and it is the
Latvian gambit I've been playing it more
and more just because it's so much fun
to see your opponent's face when you
play it they really think you have no
clue what you're doing and it's really
fun to play
so pawn to e4 upon e5 pretty common
Knight to f3 which you're gonna see all
the times you're gonna have many many
opportunities to actually play the
Latvian game it and then you're gonna
play pawn to f5 pretty crazy opening
there's a lot of different ways that
white can respond to this especially if
they've never seen it they may try
something super crazy so that's why
there's another video specifically about
that but the lab being game it is
extremely aggressive opening up the King
side over here there's a lot of
different ways to bring the bishop here
to c5 and actually give up material even
the rook or the Queen if you want to and
just go ahead and attack this square
here on f2 so a lot of different ways
you can do this but no matter how you
slice it the lab and gamete is
definitely one of the best aggressive
openings
rounding out our list of best aggressive
openings is the fried liver attack it's
just so much fun I had to include it on
the list pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop here to a c4 gotta love
the light squared bishop in an
aggressive opening Knight to f6 all very
very common moves White has many
different ways you could play could play
pretty passive with King castling on the
kingside he could play pawn pushing
forward Knight to c3 these are all fun
but these are all boring and that's why
we play the fried liver attack and
that's with Knights here to g5 getting
ready to play Knight taking here on f7
could also if you really wanted to play
Bishop here on f7 but all in all White's
looking to exchange material off the
board
a lot of material get that King here to
f7 go ahead and get that Queen involved
into the game attacking if he needs to
and just chase this King all over the
board if you haven't played it I
definitely recommend if you haven't
watched the video also recommend
watching that there's a lot more to this
so many different lines that both sides
can go to but all in all it is a
fantastic opening and definitely makes
the top of the best chess aggressive
lines that I have so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video if you have any more
requests for top video openings or
anything else you'd like to see let me
know if you have some other aggressive
openings that I didn't include in this
list feel free to leave a comment let me
know I'm always looking for some great
aggressive openings in chess but
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
I'll see you on the next one thanks for
watching